non mais moi je dirais simplement que on
sait très bien dans d'autres sociétés
que l'audace elle est souvent critiquée
et quasiment toujours jalousée nous
quand on a lancé balance ton poste il y
a trois ans c'était une volonté de créer
des débats de société avec les acteurs
de la société on ne pouvait pas imaginer
faire des débats sur les gilets jaunes
sans les gilets jaunes on ne pouvait pas
imaginer parler d'islam et de femmes qui
portent le voile sans les femmes qui
portent le voile on ne pouvait pas
imaginer parler de migrants sans avoir à
mon nom immigrant parler de la crise de
la covid et de ceux qui ont des
tentations suicidaires parce qu'il y a
un mal-être sur la santé mentale qui est
colossale sans parler de ceux qui sont
des indépendants qui sont au bord du
gouffre des étudiants qui prennent
aujourd'hui des antidépresseurs donc le
concept de notre émission c'est pas de
parler à la place des autres c'est
d'inviter les acteurs pour qu'ils
puissent s'exprimer mais aussi recevoir
la contradiction ce soir l'exercice
c'était pas de faire la promotion de
génération identitaire ce soir
l'exercice était de mettre en lumière le
logiciel de pensée la vision que
génération identitaire a de notre pays
si c'était fondamental parce qu'on ne
peut pas traiter les questions d'une
telle importance
quelle est l'image que nous voulons
avoir de notre pays comment nous voulons
vous nous voulons faire France ensemble
quels sont les valeurs de qui nous
relient avec des origines des parcours
différentes et des histoires tout ça
c'est c'est le creuser c'est le ciment
de la nation républicaine qui s'appelle
la France or c'est bien que ce soir une
jeune fille de 21 ans dont ça n'était
pas le procès nous ne sommes pas un
tribunal
Jean-Michel vient s'exprimer il a son
ronde de table donc seront serviettes
donc
son poste
à mon goût il vient un peu trop souvent
mais ça c'est mon goût moins souvent
j'étais un peu frustré ce soir parce que
j'ai beaucoup écouté mais je trouve
regrettable que finalement on est
focalisé sur quelques sujets qui quelque
part nous a qu'on peut à nous égarer
votre votre combat c'est pas que c'est
pas que l'immigrants on en a beaucoup
parlé c'est une des dimensions bien sûr
votre combat c'est pas que l'immigration
c'est une des dimensions votre combat il
est très simple vous avez une conception
de la nation qui est unique exactement
face à une conception que nous avons je
crois majoritairement qui ne conception
d'une France qui porte des valeurs et
soit on est dans le face à face auquel
vous nous invitez se définir par des
déterminismes la croyance religieuse la
classe sociale la couleur de peau d'où
viennent nos parents soit ton fut franc
sans ça d'une autre manière et on dit
nous sommes tous français ici il n'y a
pas des Français plus importants que
d'autres en revanche nous avons une
exigence au-delà de nos origines nous
devons un moment donné nous dépasser
partager des valeurs communes ces
valeurs elles ne sont pas j'ai envie de
dire un palpable contrairement à ce que
vous imaginez liberté c'est une valeur
qui est fondamentale d'ailleurs la
première des sécurités c'est d'aller en
toute liberté l'égalité mademoiselle
c'est pouvoir être traité de la même
manière par une tribunal
indépendamment de sa couleur de peau
c'est pouvoir
revendiquer des droits mais aussi
devoirs quel que soit ses origines son
histoire la fraternité c'est de faire
des soupes qui sont pas des soupe aux
pores quand on va aller vers les SDF
parce qu'on veut pas mettre de côté les
SDF juifs et musulmans mais on veut
servir la cause de la solidarité avec un
grand S or aujourd'hui vous nous
proposez une nation où on se regarderait
un chien de faïence où on s'affronterait
en fonction d'une histoire mais moi je
ne veux pas de la compétition des
mémoires vous avez votre histoire je la
respecte j'ai la mienne vous la
respectez vous n'êtes pas plus française
que moi je ne suis pas plus français que
vous l'idée que vous faites de la France
est une idée
erronée vous nous proposer une idée de
la France j'ai envie de dire que que qui
est un fantasme qui n'est pas la réalité
la République c'est un détail
elle va finir après la République ça
n'est détails c'est ce qui fait notre
ciment
l'essentiel de ce qu'il a la République
française ce soir c'était important que
vous soyez là parce qu'on a fait lumière
sur bien des sujets que vous masquez que
vous cachez vous ne pouvez pas imaginer
aimer quelqu'un qui n'a pas le même
couleur de peau vous rendez compte dans
quelle France vous voulez nous faire
vivre ce que vous avez une imaginez pas
et vous comme vous parlez d'immigration
vous comprenez
on va partir immigration
issue des migration mais attendez mais
je vais vous dire un moment donné quand
on fait la politique il faut un minimum
d'exigence
intellectuels vous n'avez pas cette
exige il est 22h ça me donne on doit
rendre l'antenne à 22h59 après il y a
que vous avez une minute allez-y Thaïs
c'est bien les tensions que nous que
nous dénonçons c'est une réalité ce
n'est pas moi qui le dise même Gérard
Collomb qui avait déclaré que
aujourd'hui nous vivons côte à côte et
demain nous devons vivre face à face
mais qui entre qui et qui mademoiselle
une partition à venir si jamais la
politique migratoire n'était pas fléchie
le problème c'est des références très
populaires la réalité c'est que les
migration dont vous parlez c'est très
beau sur le papier c'est madame vous
parlez de migrations
la réalité c'est que les Français
l'immigration qu'il côtoient c'est celle
qui les agresse c'est cette génial
c'est génétique
sur 800 m cet été pour une voiture de
raquette
tiré par le véhicule ça c'est la mort